parasite's big splash as the first
foreign language film to win best
picture at the academy awards was
probably
a lot of people's introduction to bong
joon ho but there are six other films
that came before parasite
and since parasite is now the most
covered film on my channel
i thought maybe i should watch the rest
of bong's films that i haven't seen and
share my thoughts on his filmography as
a whole
ranking these movies is mostly a
clickbait excuse to be able to talk
about bong's entire filmography
and how it evolved leading up to
parasite and after watching all his
films i don't think bong has ever made
what i would call
a bad film i like all of them so don't
be offended if your favorite is lower
than you think it should be
but i'm sure i'll hear what i got
horribly wrong in the comments anyway
i'm gonna do my best to avoid spoilers
thanks to mubi for sponsoring this video
go to mubi.com thomasflight for your
extended 30-day free trial
number seven is barking dogs never bite
this is bong's first feature-length film
and probably a pretty uncontroversial
rating there's a lot of weird little
aspects of this film that resurface
in parasite like the use of the
subterranean as an environment
bong's first film is a great first
effort but it lacks some of the finesse
and cohesion that we'll see
in some of his other films what we do
get though is a solid
introduction to bong's dark sense of
humor barking dogs never bite is about a
man's attempt to get rid of a barking
dog that's driving him crazy
this is the opening scenario and things
just kind of spiral from here
we also get an introduction to bong's
ability to use camera movement in
inventive ways like this shot where he
emphasizes the beginning of a scheme
with a unique camera movement
it almost looks like he has the actors
standing on a dolly with the camera
yeah he also uses color specifically red
and yellow in a very fun way
in this film and the jazzy soundtrack is
a lot of fun
the film pays special attention to the
economic struggles of the working and
lower class
a theme that will become pervasive
throughout all his work
ultimately though as a dramatic comedy
it doesn't quite develop
its dramatic or comedic side enough for
me it's not quite funny enough to hold
its own as a comedy and doesn't quite
have enough happening dramatically for
me to get fully invested in the
characters
number six on my list is aksha akja is
at its core a film about a girl's
friendship with a super pig
the performance from siohan on the girl
who plays misha
is phenomenal she does a great job
selling the relationship between herself
and akja if that relationship didn't
work the movie would fall apart and i
think
it does work well it's my favorite
aspect of the film
while i'm consistently impressed by
bong's use of camera in terms of
composition and movement
akja is one of his best looking films in
terms of
lighting and color grading even bong's
most serious films have some darkly
comedic
elements but some of his films more
starkly contrast his cynical world view
against an almost playful aesthetic
dark comedy isn't really the right word
here akja and a few of bang's other
films to me feel more like their comedic
horror films
this is an unspeakable
place i appreciate the way
bong is willing to really combine these
two elements and the way he does
gives his films a very unique tone but i
think aksha might be the film that most
struggles to get this tone right
for me akja's lighter side moves from
the realm of playfully comedic
into goofiness and i don't think it
quite manages that balancing act
it almost feels like a really horrifying
kids movie but obviously it's not
do as you're told otherwise this
is what will happen to ota i will say i
really love my favorite actor tilda
swinton in this
lucy morando is pulling off the
impossible she is
making us fall in love with a creature
that we are already looking forward to
eating i mean these
are journalists who never write about
pigs but
this isn't my favorite tildebond collab
and even though i usually like jake
gyllenhaal
you don't even know if she can do
anything but cry whatever he's up to in
this performance is
not doing it for me long is pretty
political in his filmmaking and i
usually like the way he explores
political topics or
issues but while his other films use
clever metaphors to help illustrate and
elucidate his point of view
this film isn't a metaphor so much as a
caricature of the darkest elements of
factory farming
which is fine metaphors aren't
necessarily better than addressing an
issue directly but i find it less
compelling personally
number five is the host this is an
absolutely bonkers movie
especially to watch right now while
we're facing a pandemic
[Laughter]
and the political fallout of that
pandemic some of bong's films i really
feel like he's making almost with a bit
of a smirk and a wink
and this is definitely one of those
films
in one of the subplots of the film the
united states is brought in to help
south korea deal with the outbreak of a
virus
which with the context of 2020 now adds
an additional layer of ironic humor to
the film
this was bong's third film and he took
the same casual dark humor that he used
in barking dogs never bite and applied
it to a blockbuster style monster movie
this is the first film of his that
harnesses a popular genre
for a much broader allegorical message
the details of this allegory and the
political themes he's exploring
here are more specific to south korea
than snow piercers akjas or parasites
and so some of the nuance may be lost on
some western audience members
but even if you don't grasp its
political metaphor you'll still get a
fun
suspenseful darkly comedic monster film
while some of the cgi hasn't aged super
well the monster itself is very
inventive and i love the way it moves
and gets around
like in barking dogs never bite there's
some great use of color again
red and yellow and bong returns to the
subterranean as an environment
and the economic struggles of the lower
class in this film we really start to
see bong's ability to
shift a film from being one type of
thing to another fairly seamlessly
number four is snow piercer this was
bong's first english language film and
so prior to parasite probably most
english speakers
introduction to his work it was the
first bong's films that i saw
like the host snow piercer uses a genre
concept
this time a dystopian sci-fi as the
basis for a more interesting social
commentary while the perspective of the
working and lower class is central to
all of bong's films
kirbang begins addressing class and
economic disparity as
a subject matter itself i really like
this movie i think the concept is
compelling and bong has a way of writing
twists and revelations so that they
aren't just surprising but force you to
suddenly reconsider the metaphor he's
created from a new angle
there's something about the simplicity
of using the physical space from left to
right and the back of the train to the
front of the train as an illustration of
class distinction that i really like
it shows bang's attention to how the
details of a film like set design and
screen direction that are often
overlooked for these uses can be used
to help tell the story and convey its
themes some of the sci-fi aspects of the
film don't really hold up under even the
slightest scrutiny but for me it's not a
huge deal because i
ultimately don't see this as a hard
sci-fi film that's just the genre shell
that bong is utilizing for dramatic
social commentary this movie also has
one of my favorite tilda swinton
performances
bang often seems to be trying to present
certain characters or scenarios in a
ridiculous
absurd and almost cartoonish way would
you wear a shoe on your head
but without stripping the actual
sinister element
out of the performance or situation and
this is something that swinton
seems to be able to do extremely well
with this character
the last three films in my list stand
apart from the rest of bong's
filmography
these three aren't as genre driven as
the others operating much
more like straight dramatic thrillers if
you want you could classify mother and
memories of murder as neo-noirs but
that's a fairly loose genre and they
don't adhere to it strictly wabang's
work with composition and camera
movement is solid across his entire
filmography and these films bangs
attention to mison scene the placement
of his actors
the movement of the camera and how the
pacing of the story flows
stands apart as particularly masterful
number three is mother in between the
host and snow piercer
bong made a very different sort of film
this is probably bong's most serious
and slowest paced film and in a sense
it's his smallest in scale
it primarily focuses on kim hija as she
searches for the killer who framed her
son for murder
here's a little example from the
beginning of the film of how bong plays
with misdirection and tension
the mother is chopping some herbs and
she's watching her son in the street
everything about how the scene is shot
and edited
is pulling our attention towards her
fingers and the blade
making us think she's going to cut
herself
but at the dramatic climax of the scene
she doesn't that tension was just a
misdirection from the real climactic
action if you watch bong's work you'll
see he does this kind of thing a lot not
just in small moments but in how he
structures his stories
in one sense mother is a character study
and another it's a rare
female-led neo-noir there's a melancholy
beneath the surface of all bong's films
but here i think it's most clearly
visible this movie does a perfect job of
being what it is and i think technically
this film is as well crafted as memories
of murder and
almost as well crafted as parasite but
at least upon first watch
for me it's a much less accessible film
emotionally than memories of a murder
and less interesting thematically than
parasite and it also lacks the same
darkly comedic
smirk that i like in a lot of bong's
other work which is what keeps it
number three for me
number two is memories of murder this is
bang's second film and it's one of his
best
memories of murder is a sort of neo-noir
detective thriller which in a way is the
perfect environment for bong's
cynical sense of humor
there are two elements of this film that
i think are actually stronger than
parasite the first
is its characters
while i love parasites characters and
the performances parasites tight pace
structure and ensemble cast means that
its story and thematic message
overshadow the individual journey of any
one character
memories of murder really allows us to
spend time with and feel
the personal internal struggle that the
detectives it focuses on
are facing the other element where i
think the film outperforms parasite is
with some of its
specific imagery i've made a whole video
praising and talking about the
effectiveness
of parasites cinematography and parasite
cinematography
does an amazing job of telling the story
but there's a striking quality to many
of the compositions and memories of
murder
that have made them lodge themselves in
my brain in a way that many images from
parasite haven't even after repeat
viewings
from parasite i remember the tone mood
movement and feeling of the scenes
but i doubt i'll ever forget these three
images from memories of murder
these striking images don't just look
cool bong uses them to punctuate
important moments and shifts in the
story
[Music]
number one is parasite no surprise here
if you've been watching my channel this
year
parasite feels like a culmination of
much of bang's other work to me
the examination of social issues through
the film's design like we see in the
host and snow piercer the precision of
craft and misunscene from mother and
memories of murder
and the cynical humor of barking dogs
never bite and akja
come together to create something really
fantastic obviously there's a lot i like
about this film and i'm not going to
rehash
all that here i'll just say what i love
the most about parasite is the way
it flows the rhythm of the edit mixed
with bong's best use of music
the movement from scene to scene and
revelation to revelation really makes
you feel like you're slipping deeper
into this world in an irrevocable way
there's a lot to examine in bong's other
films but here we find
layers behind every frame it's a film
that at first glance to me
feels effortless but when examined
reveals that
every element is fine-tuned almost
within an inch of its life
from bong joon-ho's entire filmography
we get a sense of a director who has a
keen
eye for identifying and illustrating the
darker side of humanity and society he
offers
few solutions and little hope to those
problems but his
wry sense of humor lightens the blow
enough for audiences to actually
look these issues in the face we see a
director who cares deeply about the form
of film giving great care to how he uses
the camera
and his actors but who isn't rigid in
how he approaches
genre structure or tone he's certainly
a unique voice in the contemporary
landscape and i'm glad more people
myself included are being exposed to his
work as a result of parasite's success
i look forward to seeing what he does
next if you're interested in learning
about film and filmmaking i think
examining a director's work as a whole
is a great exercise so if you're a fan
of parasite or a few of bong joon ho's
other films i definitely recommend
checking out
bong's entire filmography for yourself
let me know in the comments which of his
films are your favorites and why
this video is brought to you by mubi
mubi is like your own
personal film festival it's a curated
streaming service
showing you exceptional films from
around the world
every day they premiere a new film
sometimes i'll find something i've been
wanting to watch for a long time and
sometimes i'll find a new
favorite that i wouldn't have discovered
any other way with fewer new releases
happening this year
mubi's hand curated library is a great
way to find
new and interesting films that you want
to watch whether they're timeless
classics call favorites or indie art
house films
right now on the movie library you can
watch the 2015 german film victorio
which is a 139 minute film that was shot
entirely in one take it's a really cool
film that i recommend you check out for
free when you sign up for your free
trial at mubi.com
thomasflight that's mubi.com
thomasflight
thanks for watching and special thank
you to my patrons for their ongoing
support
if you sign up to support my channel at
patreon.com thomasflight you'll get
access to special bonus content i create
like a podcast where i talk about what
i've been watching and future projects
i'm working on